und ich war in der Lage, etwas sogar Depressives zu erschaffen,
und hier kam etwas Fröhliches heraus,
weil ich dann wusste, dass es in mir war,
und ich möchte, dass die Leute wissen,
dass dies eine chromatische Axt ist, die meine
Perspektive ist, in der
ich die
Übersetzung von Buchstaben lese  junger dichter nun,
es war sehr jung und das ist einer
der gründe, warum ich
eigentlich liederschreiber bin, weil ich mir diese frage gestellt habe
, wenn das zitat in den tiefsten
stunden der nacht ist, frag dich, ob du sterben müsstest,
wenn dir das
schreiben verboten würde  Schau tief in dein Herz, wo
die Antwort ihre Wurzeln ausbreitet, und frage dich, was
du am meisten tun musst
Wenn wir alle ein Licht in uns
hätten, das wir sehen könnten, das ständig
pulsiert, weißt du, ich denke, wenn ich
nicht schreibe, würdest du es irgendwie nicht
so hell pulsieren sehen, aber wenn ich schreibe
und ich singe und ich  spiele mein
Leben  Kraft wächst in meinem Licht und mein Strahl
scheint einfach überall um mich herum und dieses Album
hat mich wirklich geheilt. Chromatisch zu schreiben ist
das Album, es hat mich auf so viele Arten wirklich geheilt
Versetze dich in meine Lage
mm-hmm und ich würde sagen, weil
ich denke, dass Menschen sich so heilen,
wenn wir Geschichten teilen und
uns dann in die Lage des anderen versetzen
und versuchen zu verstehen, was jemand
fühlt, also stell dir vor, du hättest
Depressionen  und du bist so traurig und du
weißt nicht warum, weil du ein
schönes Leben hast, aber ich
habe ein biologisches physiologisches
chemisches Ungleichgewicht in meinem Körper, das
mich depressiv macht, dafür muss ich Medikamente nehmen,
und das stelle ich mir vor  Sie,
egal was jemand sagt, können sich nicht
wirklich glücklich fühlen, aber Sie haben eine Fähigkeit oder
Sie haben ein Talent, und selbst mit dieser
Fähigkeit und dieser Begabung in diesem Talent
sind Sie sich nicht sicher, ob Sie gut genug sind,
aber Sie versuchen es und dann wenn  du
Du hast es versucht und du hast zurückgesehen, was du erschaffen hast, oder du hast
zurückgehört, was du erschaffen hast,
und du hast Freude gehört, so heilst du,
wenn ich in der Lage war, etwas zu erschaffen,
sogar deprimiertes und etwas Fröhliches davon kommen hörte,
weil ich dann wusste, dass es in mir war
ich und das ist, was ich möchte
, dass die Leute wissen, das ist Chrome Attica
, das ist meine Perspektive, so
heilen wir durch Musik, und
so heilen wir auch, was auch immer wir
anbieten, wie kann ich wie kann ich versuchen,
weiterzumachen und dann  mich selbst überraschen
und einen glücklichen Fehler machen, weil ich
fünf Minuten lang an mich geglaubt habe und
meine Talente und meine Gaben eingesetzt habe und ich
gemerkt habe, dass ich tatsächlich glücklich war. Ich
habe das tatsächlich irgendwo. Ich meine, ich war
wirklich so, als wäre kein Glück in
mir.  Ich glaube nicht, dass es da war, aber ich
konnte es danach hören und ich sagte,
ich feiere, warum feiere
ich, und bevor ich es wusste, hatte ich ein ganzes Album und
dann wurde ich
zu dem, was ich heute bin, eine Frau
, die immer noch Depressionen hat, aber es ist
erholte sich so sehr a  Und ich möchte
das so vielen Menschen wie möglich geben,
wissen Sie, ich denke, in vielerlei Hinsicht war meine
Karriere wie eine Revolution gegen
Konstrukte rund um Frauen und all die
Dinge, die Männer von mir wollten, ich war
umgeben von Männern, die geben wollten  meine
Lieder an andere Frauen, die nicht
so gut singen konnten wie ich, der meine Musik nicht geschrieben hat,
und das war, weil ich nicht so hübsch war wie
sie und ich wirklich hart dafür gekämpft habe, das zu behalten,
was ich gemacht habe, und der einzige Grund, warum ich dazu gekommen bin
es wirklich zu behalten ist, weil ich es gemacht habe und
so war ich der Boss meiner eigenen Musik und
dann, wenn es an der Zeit war, Mode oder
Schönheit zu setzen oder Stil zu setzen und Kunst zu schaffen, mit
allem, was ich tat, war
ich immer subversiv, ich versuchte immer dagegen anzugehen
das Körnchen dessen, wie es war, wie ein
hübsches Mädchen oder eine schöne
Frau auszusehen, weil ich das niemandem verkaufen möchte
, und obwohl
ich meinen Körper schon einmal in meinen Outfits gefeiert habe
oder in denen ich dich kennst  Das dumme
Liebesvideo Ich tanze und ich bin stark
und ich bin in diesen, weißt du, Li  Ich trage diese
Leotard-Punk-Outfits und trete das auf,
weil ich sage, dass es in Ordnung ist,
seinen Körper auch zu lieben, als wäre ich nicht perfekt, aber
ich feiere mich selbst als Frau und ich
denke, dass
nicht nur auf Frauen, sondern auf vielen Frauen ein großer Druck lastet  Menschen müssen
mit einer Ästhetik oder einem Sinn für Perfektion Schritt halten,
und wir versuchen möglicherweise ständig
zu kontrollieren, wie alles aussieht,
damit wir akzeptiert werden können, und ich möchte das nicht
als Vorbild für die
Menschen sein, also denke ich, was ich tun würde  Sagen Sie,
wie jeder, der zusieht, hoffe ich, dass
Sie in meiner Arbeit immer wissen,
egal was ich tue, dass Sie wissen
,
dass es nicht darauf ankommt, was
ich für die sozial akzeptabelste
Sache halte  als eine schöne Person, denn wie
nett du bist,
ist der Raum in meinem Kopf,
wo ich entschieden habe, wie ich die
Welt sehe, wie ich liebe, wie ich freundlich
bin, und ich nenne mich die ganze Zeit einen Freundlichkeits-Punk,
weil ich  finde es nicht
cool, nett zu sein  Zeiten, in denen ich denke, die
Leute denken, es sei cooler, unfreundlich zu sein, oder
vielleicht in den Medien oder sozialen oder
sozialen Netzwerken oder einfach im Leben
, in denen Kritik und
Negativität sehr weit verbreitet sind, und in der
Politik und in der Politik sehr stark,
und ich wollte es  zeig das auf dem Video
und du siehst Leute kämpfen und du siehst
mich reinkommen und ich bin nicht so,
ich bin irgendwie nett, aber ich bin auch wie Mama,
die reinkommt, nein, nein, hier streitet und
ich denke, es ist ein It's  Radikal weißt du, also
nenne ich mich nur deshalb einen Freundlichkeits-Punk,
weil ich die Idee,
ein Punk zu sein, mit radikal verbinde, also wurden die
Ketten und die Stacheln, die du
in dem Video siehst, und was ich trage
, von dieser Idee dieses Seins inspiriert  Art ist
eine radikale Sache und das ist in Ordnung und
es ist eigentlich cool. Ich liebe es, wenn
Leute nett sind, und ich finde
es großartig, in der Musik anders zu sein. Es
gibt 12 Noten und eine Oktave und
sie sind chromatisch, also spricht das für beide
Farben  und zu Musik u  Ich wollte
mit diesem Albumtitel wirklich ausdrücken, dass ich
die Welt in all den Farben sehe, die du
kennst, jede Farbe, mehr Farben, als wir
uns vorstellen können, wie mehr, als ich
in einem Geschäft finden könnte, um für dich zu kreieren, dass
wir als Menschen so komplex sind und so
anders, wir sind so farbenfroh, wir sind so
genial in der Art, wie wir
geschaffen wurden, und auch wenn etwas
chromatisch ist, ist es ein halber Schritt, also ein
geschlossener Schritt, also sind wir auch sehr nahe
beieinander, du weißt, es ist und ich wollte es
machen  Dies ist eine Aussage, Sie wissen, wie ich
Menschen erde, und eine Idee, die ich habe
, die auch völlig
befreundet waren, aber auch so nahe beieinander
stehen, weil Verschiedenheit meiner Meinung nach
impliziert, dass wir getrennt sein sollten,
aber das will ich nicht  nutze alle
mir zur Verfügung stehenden Medien, um Freundlichkeit zu verbreiten.
Ich habe so ein enormes
Verständnis für meine Position in der
Welt. Ich bin mir meines Lebens sehr bewusst. Ich
weiß, dass ich berühmt bin. Ich kenne einige Leute, die
wissen, wer ich
bin  Wenn du weißt, wer ich bin, will ich dich
kn  ow auf meinem Grabstein, damit es heißt, sie
war nett, sie war mutig und sie wollte, dass
du nett bist und dass du mutig bist,
wie das sind die Dinge,
an die ich mich erinnern möchte, denn ich muss nicht
als das beste Ich in Erinnerung bleiben
Ich möchte nicht als die Königin in Erinnerung bleiben Ich muss nicht
als die größte Künstlerin aller Zeiten in Erinnerung bleiben
Ich möchte wirklich Ich Ich liebe die Welt Ich
liebe die Welt wirklich Und als
ich ins Studio kam, um zu schreiben, tat ich es  t
nur an meinen eigenen Schmerz denken, als
ich diese Songs schrieb, dachte ich darüber nach, wie
ich die Welt durch meine
Erfahrungen informieren und ihnen helfen könnte, wie ich
jemand anderem helfen kann, wie ich ein Album machen kann
, wenn jemand einen schlechten Tag hat
Schalten Sie es ein und sie fangen einfach an zu
tanzen, wie kann ich das tun, und ich habe daran
gearbeitet und daran gearbeitet und daran gearbeitet,
und alle, mit denen ich gearbeitet habe, hatten die
gleiche Vision, und das ist Gramatica